We ended up, you know,
having an abortion. And it's so weird to say
because I didn't realize that until the Dobbs decision.
When John and I were talking about it in bed one day,
and I was talking about it from a place of.
I feel so bad for people, for other people,
for them. That anyone's ever had to go through that,
and they. They're not able to make a choice about their own body. And.
And he was like, well,
you had an abortion. I was like, what?
I had no idea. That language wasn't used in.
In the room that I was in.
It was never said by my doctor.
It was never said by anyone around me.
Um, so I just assumed that I had miscarried.
I didn't even realize. And I.
I honestly felt so ignorant
for not having known that for so many years,
um, that I didn't know what was happening to my own body.
But I think that word is so scary to people.
It's so taboo to talk about.
And so I think by you speaking out about it,
by being here and all of us speaking out about it,
and knowing that millions of women around the world
make this decision for themselves,
and hearing stories from your clinic,
hearing that so many women come in there,
and it's not a place of sadness all the time.
It's not a place where people are feeling their darkest points or
Anything like the world wants you to think.
Some people go in there with so much hope and so much sorry
and so much excitement because they know that they have a future.
And maybe there are so many people,
like mand and I, that wanted our baby so badly.
And it's okay. What happened to us is okay.
But we can't let this happen to other people.
We cannot let people not have this choice.
Sharing all these stories and humanizing this taboo subject,
I think, is really an important thing. Sorry.